a centuries old secret society that
hardly anyone knows is actually a hidden
order one that's been pulling the
strings behind the scenes the Jesuits a
secret arm of the Vatican has one
Mission infiltrate and reshape what
Protestants believe and twist the truth
about your faith they're not who you
think they are during the Dark Ages
millions of Christians died at the hands
of these individuals today we are
revealing to you books that have been
preserved for hundreds of years written
by these very Jesuits and other
prominent figures of the Vatican we will
show you what they are really about and
what role they play in Bible prophecy
and the end times are you ready to
uncover what the Jesuits and the Vatican
never wanted you to see this isn't just
a story this is history and it's your
future hey real quick so in this video
we're going to discuss a religious
entity a religious system that a lot of
people follow and are part of we are in
no means attacking the people that are
part of it there are many really
beautiful genuine people who adhere to
this religion but we are talking about
the system and those who are heading it
okay so let's dive in so you guys
decided to buy a ton of very old
historical ancient books that are
written a lot of them are written by the
Jesuits yes now this is crazy guys I
don't know if you guys understand and
the gold mine that's sitting here and
how much this has to do with
prophecy and literally the end times and
even the mark of the beast so if you
want to understand this you should watch
this episode in its entirety but what do
you guys got for us today well what we
have is I mean we're really diving into
history quite literally um because we
have books here that are very old
actually um the oldest one is right here
this is the um decretum graani and this
book is actually about 460 years old wow
was this around during the Dark Ages the
Reformation okay so this this exact book
was here for for long before the the
United States was even a country that's
amazing um you know when George
Washington was crossing the Delaware
this book was sitting on a shelf when
you know the Declaration of Independence
was signed it was sitting on a shelf
it's been preserved it's been preserved
yeah um
during the French Revolution it was
there and it goes all the way back to
1559 wow so it's a it's a really old
book uh it was written by a Catholic
monk
Gan um and it has a lot of interesting
things and I thought we would kind of
jump into what it has to say it's really
excellently preserved um and you can
actually see on the pages if you flip it
open to a random page there James you
can actually see on the front cover the
tannin from the leather are seeping into
the pages and it's it's written in Latin
um and it actually has
wormholes from bookworms literally
eating their way through the pages of
the book That's How old it is
wow so um one of the interesting things
about this book and why it's important
to the Protestant
Reformation is let's turn to page
53 there's actually a statement in there
that kind of established es how
important this book was to them uh you
can actually see it right here inter
canonica scriptura um and if you
translate that to English it says among
the canonical scriptures deal Epistles
are
counted so where do where does that
place this book then how do how
important is this book so it's saying
it's unar with the scriptures meaning
the Bible right yeah that's pretty wild
it is it's it's a wild statement but
basically it underscores that this was
considered you know the the authority
the author authoritative subject on what
they had to
say so if we flip further forward to
page
131 on there um it has an interesting
statement again kind of going to that
papal Authority and how they they
basically couldn't be wrong uh we see
this long text here and it says if the
pope is found to be negligent concerning
the salvation of his Brethren useless
and remiss in his works and furthermore
silent about what is good which harms
him more and nonetheless leads countless
peoples in large groups to follow him
into the first bondage of Hell destined
to be beaten with many Stripes Forever
no mortal presumes to rebuke him for
such faults for he himself is to judge
all and is to be judged by no one so
he's saying basically Bally as we
understand it in common English he's
saying I'm above the law yes I'm above
sinh and you can't judge me for whatever
I do yes that's not biblical no that's
not what the Bible says because the only
person that is above the law is God or
and Jesus right who are reflection of
the law yep y wow so you it it really
shows this is we're beginning to see why
people in the Protestant Reformation had
an issue with this yeah
why they took an issue with the Catholic
Church's stance um if you flip forward
to page
314 it has a statement there which says
it is quite clearly shown that the
pontiff cannot be entirely bound or
loosed by secular power as it is
established that he was called a God by
the pious Prince Constantine whom we
mentioned earlier since it is Manifest
that even God cannot be judged by men H
you know one of the things that I find
interesting about this statement is in
the Latin there you can
read and that word Austin detour is an
interesting word it is the Latin word to
show or or shown and you know if you go
in your Bible in the Latin Vulgate to 2
Thessalonians 2:4 where the man of sin
shows himself to be God sitting in the
seat of God uh that word there is endin
it's the same Latin word to show and
here here the pope is literally showing
himself as God it's the direct
fulfillment of 2 Thessalonians 2:4 right
here mhm and the Bible talks about what
is blasphemy is saying that you can
forgive sins and it's saying that you
are God yeah that's literally what he's
doing he's blaspheming according to what
the scripture say it is yep right and I
think you could make some parallels
there to Daniel
7:25 shall speak great words against the
Most High um if you flip forward even
further to page 870 we find an
interesting little footnote there um it
says the enemies of the ecclesiastical
religion must also be coerced by Wars
what does it mean to be coerced by
war that means persecution right well
you actually this book was printed in
1559 but just a few years later you had
St Bartholomew's Massacre that occurred
in
1572 and this is where you actually had
a lot of the hugenots that were in Paris
at the time that were completely in one
day wiped out uh tens of thousands of
them were murdered um there was reports
that there were so many that were killed
they threw a lot of the bodies into the
is it the sign river scene River um and
uh they they had to pay city workers to
pull all the bodies out about a week
later that is insane and there there you
can see it depicted on this picture
right here yeah um but there was 1,00
bodies that were out of the river alone
this is kind of a historical depiction
of it right here and and one of the
other things is going back to Daniel
7:25 where it talks about um shall speak
great words what does it do next it
wears out the Saints it persecutes them
right yeah so it's a direct fulfillment
now I have an interesting coin right
here but this coin was actually minted
by Pope Gregory the
13th and the original coin was actually
uh minted the very same year that St
Massacre occurred and and what do you
see right here well you see an angel
with a sword holding a cross standing
over the bodies of dead hugenots and
then the other side is the image of the
Pope right yeah and so it's like I did
this just to put it in perspective
that's like Joe Biden putting his head
on one side and the other side it's just
like uh a bunch of people getting
slaughtered in the streets and that's
just everyday common money that we'll
just be like I'm going to go to the
store and buy a lollipop and uh here
take this coin like that that's that
doesn't make sense no but you know if we
go to Revelation 17 there's this Harlot
who is literally drinking blood you know
drinking this cup of blood and so this
is exactly what we see you know
happening in history is this kind of
persecution of tens of thousands of
people and some of these massacres so um
one of the other interesting things
about this coin Act actually is if you
see the red area on this coin that's
actually a striking
imperfection so this that's the physical
coin we have right here and the reason
is because the original coin was minted
in 1572 we actually have a restrike
which means that they kept making
further copies of the coin the one we
have is from the
1600s but they kept restriking the same
coin for hundreds of years wow so it
wasn't just a celebration of St
Bartholomew's massacre at that time in
1572 it wasn't just a poor decision that
one time it was a continued like we did
a good thing for many years to come um
and so it's not just a you know onetime
mistake yeah they wanted people to
remember and what's the better way to to
remind people of what you've done than
just to give them something and use on a
daily basis right yep yep so then what
what is interesting is you had the
Protestant Reformation that was kind of
building steam at this time and is it
any wonder that people started calling
out the Roman Catholic church and saying
this is the beast power that's spoken of
this is the Antichrist power and so we
actually see evidence of that in these
pages right here so these Pages they're
in their protective uh film WP right
there but those are pages from the 1583
Geneva Bible what's the Geneva Bible so
the Geneva Bible is an early English
translation it actually came about
before the King James version which was
in
1611 and these pages right here it
actually flips there you go um these
pages right here are single pages from
the 1583 Geneva Bible now what's
interesting is this is the book that the
pilgrims would have had when they came
over on the Mayflower mhm so this is the
Bible not this exact one necessarily but
this is the same Bible that came over on
the Mayflower which was the people
coming from Europe to the United States
right because they were fleeing
persecution as Protestant Christians
they were being persecuted by the Roman
Catholic Church correct Y and we
actually have specific proof of that in
this these actual Pages because it says
that this is a commentary on Revelation
13 Verse
18 and this is the verse in Revelation
that talks about the 666 power
you know it says right here here is
wisdom let him that hath wit count the
number of the Beast for it is the number
of a man this number is 6003 score and6
MH so that's that's the verse in
Revelation and then we actually see
their footnotes here right next to it
and these footnotes give us an
interesting understanding of what they
believed yes so this is not the verses
it's commentary on the verses correct
yes um and this is a a large Pulpit
Bible so this would have been used up
it's kind of like a study Bible that
we'd have today so they have different
commentary so that they kind of know
roughly the context of what they're
talking about and it says right there
such as may be understood by man's
reason for about 666 years after this
Revelation the pope or Antichrist began
to be manifest in the world so we know
that the pilgrims that came over the
foundation of this
country is based off of an understanding
that protestantism was correct and that
Catholicism was a fulfillment of
Prophecy Y and they took this from other
reformers who also believed that this
was the Antichrist which which reformers
were they specifically that that said
the pope is the Antichrist and out of
the and out of these reformers what
churches came about what
denominations well you've got the
Lutheran you've got Martin Luther
lutherans yeah you've got the
Presbyterians you've got you know John
Calvin you've got um you know of course
the Calvinists that came from him uh
basically there's a whole long list of
probably 30 or 40 different reformers
that we could list off uh right off the
bat but they were unified on this
perspective uh for for many many many
years and it wasn't until later on
when the Counter Reformation introduced
the idea of preterism or futurism that
you really see a um a change in
Protestant thought on that you know here
we have a prophecy in Revelation 13:18
talking about the number of the of the
Beast is 6003 score
and6 do we have a fulfillment of that in
this book that's the interesting
question yeah I would like to see that
so if we go to page 316 oh here it comes
there's a section from the Donation of
Constantine now the Donation of
Constantine this was a a Roman Imperial
decree and it was supposedly from
Constantine and was giving the Catholic
Church
Authority political Authority um it was
later proved to be a forgery but that
didn't stop it from being included in
this book which you know as we talked
about earlier was co- enumerated with
canonical
scripture so you know they they included
a section from the Donation of
Constantine which is an older work in
this book and what do we see there we
see a curious title given for the pope
and that title is vicarious
fil and in in English it means Vicor of
the Son of God James what does the word
vicer mean well you got substitute uh
one of the things that our Catholic
apologists will often say is is well
this wasn't a legitimate title vicarius
Christi is the actual legitimate title
uh the problem is is that vicarius
christe is synonymous with vicarius f um
you know unless you're going to deny
that Christ is the Son of God but uh if
go to Leviticus
24:18 go to go to that text and look and
you'll see that there's a substitute
Beast the substitute is referred to in
the Latin Vulgate as viarum in the Greek
when it says life for life it says an um
the word there for or substitute is anti
so
viarum is basically analogous to anti in
the sense of vicarius Christi you end up
with Antichrist vicarius Christ meaning
Antichrist and you know vicarious filad
of course not only was it connected here
in uh canon law very much authoritative
we don't need to go look for Tiaras or
Tri regnum or or hats or anything to
kind of substantiate it we can go direct
to canon law but he also had it on his
hat or something like so there there's
some controversy over that because
nobody's got any photographs of it but
then again I don't I don't see any
photographs of Gregory V 16 1845 T
floating around on the internet either
so there are some uh there are some
thums that haven't been photographed but
um you know the problem with with this
uh idea of the Donation of Constantine
being a forgery is when it was revealed
by lenus Vala as a forgery they put his
work on the index lium prohibitorum at
the Council of Trent so in other words
they tried to silence The Whistleblower
who warned that the Donation of
Constantine was a forgery so you know
and and not only that you can also see
the Donation of Constantine featured in
these Jesuit books here as well going
way back to the first century so Rome
relied on it and this title actually was
used by numerous popes uh you can go
take a look right now on the Vatican
website to this day and you will find
Pope Paul I 6 using this title right up
on the Vatican website to this very day
in the opening kind of uh incipit of
some of his documents so this this title
is still up on the Vatican website to
this day it is very much a legitimate
title and you know if you want to look
more on you can look to Johannes Quon
The Quon document a famous uh Catholic
apologist from uh the Catholic
University in Washington DC who said
that it was a very common as a title for
the pope and so if you actually look at
Revelation 13:18 some translations will
actually read that it is the number of a
name well so if you're using this as a
title vicarius fil and that's the title
for the pope if you count it up the in
in the Roman numerals you get vicarius
112 uh fi 53 and day 501 that adds up to
666 and the reason that this has made
even more of an impression on me is
because if you go to the cover page of
this book where it actually has the year
listed they don't list it in numbers now
the page numbers are in in regular
numbers that we would recognize today
but right there it actually has the the
date the book was printed in Roman
numerals M so it was a common practice
to use Roman numerals to number things
MH so can we apply that same principle
to Vicarious fly day which we have
physical proof of right here yeah and
like you said uh nowadays we don't say
oh the letter d has a number but back in
the day that was part of it they said uh
I think V is like five or something and
I is one and and so this was a normal
way of life a normal way of counting
things using letters Roman letters that
also meant numbers mhm and it's it it's
also a Blasphemous title right in place
of the Son of God yeah so it's BL yeah
it's blasphemy again according to the
scriptures the definition of it yes yes
so if we go on from there we uh I have
another interesting book this is a
pontifical romanum right here and this
little book it's kind of a a pocket book
do you see that you you could slide that
into your pocket if you were if you were
a priest you could slide that into your
robes take a look at the guilting around
it that's that's Gold Leaf that they
would you know put around it it's
honestly kind of a pretty little book
but it has some interesting things
inside it it has a quote on page I think
62 that says I swear that Heretics and
schismatics and Rebels to our Lord the
Lord Pope or his successors I will to
the extent of my power persecute and
beat down
impugn and so you have again that system
of coercion right mhm that if you didn't
follow what the pope and and they pushed
you were going to be persecuted you were
going to be beat down you going to be
attacked that word in panabo you can
also translate it to to attack so chase
them down attack them you know when
people talk about whether or not the
Jesuit oath is genuine um they often
reference you know I was a forgery from
Robert wear when I go back to Robert
wear's third work in foxes and fire
Brands uh
uh you know you can actually go back to
one of the Oaths that he has in there
and he references Clement I find
interesting we got Clement here right on
the front of this book kind of a Roman
WR book but you know it's easy to see
that within some of these Works were
these kinds of aggressive Oaths uh you
know it really makes me lean towards the
idea that there were some secret Oaths
there were some Oaths to persecute and
beat down uh because you can see
evidence of that right here and so yeah
because the you know talking about this
how it talks about to persecute and beat
down the Jesuits came about to counter
the Reformation that was happening in
the Dark Ages people were starting to
speak up Christians were saying what you
are doing Roman Catholic Church isn't
right this isn't
biblical and um the Roman Catholic
Church really originated with paganism
creeping into the Christian church and
then out of it over many years in the
Roman Catholic church so when these
Protestants started standing up for it
um and said start speaking up people
like Martin Luther and Don Calvin came
about and Wesley um the Roman Catholic
Church was like wait a minute there's
too many people leaving our church and
they were making a lot of money off of
people y that were you know oh you will
burn in hell forever or you will go to
Purgatory unless you give us a little
money you know they were super wealthy
off of that they were like well we need
we we need to make sure we keep their
money we need to get the money flowing
in you know we need to get wealthy off
of these these poor Christians who don't
know any better then they came about
with the Jesuit order which was really
to counter the Reformation to infiltrate
these Protestant churches to pull them
back but in your video about the Jesuits
that we talk about we show you there are
a secret society there are the Vatican
secret
society um in that video you have the
oath of the Jesuits and they literally
swear their life to it that they will
listen to the pope and if the pope tells
them you should kill these Protestants
whether you cut open the pregnant lady's
wombs whether you do this or that to
them it doesn't matter you do it and
they swear their life to it and that's
the people that wrote some of these
books it's an incredibly graphic oath oh
absolutely you know if if you read
through it it kind of makes you sick
just reading it and that's why a lot of
people have tried to say like oh this
isn't real and yet we have proof of a
similar oath that's saying that you
should attack pursue beat down right
here Y and so is it is it a far stretch
to say no it's it's legit yeah
um so if we go further forward we
actually start to get into the some of
the actual Jesuit books that start
talking about what they actually
believed so these these books right here
are actually a collection of Works
written by two different Jesuit
Philipe LA and Gabriel Kosar and if you
see under the cover page actually it
says the Society of Jesus um which is
the Jesuit
order and so these books are actually
kind of a collection of different
decrees ecumenical councils this is
basically the historical account of the
who's who and what said what for
hundreds of years it actually goes back
for thousands of years and H and you
know one of the things too we want to
make sure we're point out here is a lot
of this history is actually even before
the Jesuits came along before The
Counter Reformation but it's told
through their their lens and through
their
historians and they were the ones that
actually helped write it down and make
sure that it was remembered and it was
then used as reference material for
other priests to look at and say oh okay
well this was what was decided let's go
ahead and go with that so in a lot of
ways they they were the ones to help
push it but we see here actually on this
first exhibit that we prohibit also that
the Le should be permitted to have the
books of the old or new testament unless
anyone from motive of devotion should
wish to have the Salter or the brevy for
divine offices or the hours of the
Blessed Virgin but we most strictly
forbid their having any translation of
these books so there you go the Dark
Ages right yep and and I want to make a
point here that there's not a word here
about those being faulty translations
it's just that you can't have any
translations at all and this actually
came out of uh the Council of Trent as
well uh in the index lium prohibitorum
you find a statement that begins
manim uh basically the statement
inam it's on the vatican's website is
that uh we find that when the scripture
is freely given to the Ley it causes
more harm than good and so their their
observation was is if you if you allow
the Bible freely to the leoty more harm
is done than good uh and that's why they
prohibited the Bible is because the
bible really exposed Rome for what she
is yeah it's interesting as they say it
does more harm than good well to who
exct it does good to the people we need
to have the light that's that's why it
was called the Dark Ages because they
prohibited yes you to have the Bible and
it's interesting uh that I I I was
baptized as a baby in the Catholic
Church my grandparents were catholic
their whole life and so I had to do the
communion thing and the classes and all
that kind of stuff I was given a rosary
to pray with and um only the the priest
up front would actually open some kind
of a either it was like a Roman book or
sometimes it was the scriptures but
nobody ever really help their Bibles
like when I go to church I bring my
Bible with me and when someone's
preaching up front everybody has their
Bible open and you read along with it um
and and that was not done back then
right it was like you cannot have the
scriptures and besides it's only in
Latin and those reformers that tried to
translate the Bible in the common
language like German like Luther did um
and and English those people were
persecuted mhm and and the the Bibles
that they were were there were copies
made of those translations they were
burned mhm and why is that it's because
if you study the scriptures you come to
an understanding that coercion is
antithetical to the scriptures MH God is
not a god of coercion we have the free
will choice to choose to serve him
that's
right so that went even further and
eventually you had those that were
opposed
to Rome's Doctrine burned at the stake
yeah um many of them yeah the Pines for
example they were a a group of people in
Northern Italy they lived a very simple
kind of AIC lifestyle they were opposed
to the wealth and the power of the
Catholic church and they were
subsequently persecuted along with a lot
of others and so it says you're burned
in alive in the sight of men y we decide
that they affect that
that they may be burned alive in the
sight of men by the fiery
judgment yeah this this uh bull right
here you can find actually supporting
the Constitutions of Frederick the the
emperor at the time but Kum
adverum it's actually uh one that's not
been widely written about but follows up
Pope Innocent IV's original bull adct
sta which uh instituted and began kind
of some of the torture in the the time
time of the uh Inquisition and it's
interesting that among the names
enumerated in some of these documents
from innocent I 4th as far as the pines
and some of their cohorts you have the
Leonas or the alenes or the wild denes
here as well so there were a number of
groups that were featured here who were
condemned to the
flames and so think about that for a
second we have a book here this one this
one's not written by Jesuit but it it's
from
1559 you had people that were burned at
the stake after this book was
printed H you know you had in about 10
years after this book was printed you
had Dirk
Willams and he was a uh I believe he was
an
anabaptist and he was captured because
he was a Protestant and he was held in
prison and he managed to escape he
escaped prison and it was winter time
and he fled across a frozen moat wow uh
running you know to try and escape and
get away but he was pursued by guards
and the guards were chasing him and as
he was on that moat you know he's
probably thinner and running and pretty
lightweight from being in in jail but
the the guard chasing him was heavier
and subsequently fell through the
ice and Dirk
Willams was then stuck with a conundrum
does he let somebody who's drowning
suffer just so that he can escape with
his own life or does he turn around he
made the Fateful decision to turn around
so he goes back and he drags the guard
out of the Ice Water pulls him to safety
and as a result of doing that they
recaptured him and they subsequently you
know said well doesn't matter that he
rescued the guard he's still guilty and
so they burned him at the stake and this
book right here was 10 years old when
that happened you know one of the things
that I find interesting about that story
is there's going to be a lot of people
out there that say well Protestants were
involved in some of the wars against
Catholicism but you know what uh there
are people like Dirk Willams who went
back and demonstrated the spirit of
Christ in loving their enemy even if it
meant giving their own life for their
enemy that's the spirit we ought to have
towards those who disagree with us is
not that we're going to go fight them
back in a war but we would be willing to
lay down our life to give them a second
chance to know Christ yeah I think a lot
of us can learn something from that I
mean man I think I I think as as even as
Christians sometimes we can react to
other Christians lashing out saying
something and we're just like in our
heads maybe just just grumbling about
them and then here's an individual is
like I'm going to die if I help this
person he tried to kill me burn me alive
he says I'm going to save your life and
I will uh lay down mine right
so you think about it these pages though
that are calling for the death of those
who are standing for the truth they're
really kind of metaphorically dripping
with blood yeah I mean all of these
books are um and we see that further
with the next book actually which is
that white one over there there's an
interesting quote in this and it's
talking about how to coer those who
disagree because it wasn't just that
they were going to put
Protestants to death it was also that
they wanted them to recant their ways
and believe what the church believed and
so there's a a statement here um adct
stpa Rule
25 the head of the state or ruler must
Force must force all the Heretics whom
he has in his custody provided he does
so without killing them or breaking
their arms or legs as actual robbers and
murderers of Souls and thieves of the
sacraments of God and Christian faith to
confess their errors and accuse other
Heretics whom they know and specify
their motives and Those whom they have
seduced and those who have lodged them
and defended them as thieves and robbers
of material goods are made to accuse
their accomplice and confess the crimes
they have
committed
so that in essence
is legislating torture mhm we can do
whatever we want to try and force them
mhm but you just can't can't kill them
and break their arms and their legs
right and and also to tell them who are
you working with who are the other
Protestants I was reading a book by um
uh it's that nonprofit organization the
voice of the martyrs they put out a book
about a couple of females of various
Christian females throughout the world
um who went through Pro persecution and
this one is about sedina wor brand her
husband Richard rbrand founded the voice
of the martyrs and it was her story as
she was in prison and the Soviets were
doing the same thing they said we want
to know who you are who your your other
Christians are who's your pastor who are
the other people you're worshiping with
and if you don't tell us we will torture
you everybody knows how evil that time
was in the Soviet Union and and what
they were doing to Christians but that's
not new no that it's I mean this was
happening in Europe where now we're
think oh this is such a safe place but
if we understand prophecy understand the
mark of the beast Revelation 13 we know
this will come back and we have to make
a take make a stand for Jesus and that's
I think one of the most important points
is why why go into all this history why
bring these old books why buy these
ancient documents from hundreds of years
ago it's because as we study the past we
learn how history repeats itself
Ecclesiastes says it mhm and so we know
that as as we look toward the future we
can see some of these things are going
to resurface there's actually in that
white book before you get to ad extraa
Rule 25 there's a statement in there
that says therefore by these Apostolic
writings we command your community that
each of you should cause the same
constitutions to be inscribed in your
chapter records never to be abolished at
any time and that according to them you
proceed without any Omission against
every heresy that rises against this
holy church h
so it's saying never to be abolished
that was what was stated yeah and so
will we see any of the principles in
these books brought up again I I believe
so yeah
100% so there's another statement
here and this is again kind of
highlighting how this is the Antichrist
power because in Revelation it talks
about the mark of the beast m will cause
all to to have the mark of the beast and
without it they can't buy or sell right
we actually see precedent for that
talked about in these books neither let
any Commerce be held with them in
selling and buying that the comfort of
humanity having been lost they may be
compelled to return from the error of
their way so that's coercion right there
yep that's coercion in saying the
comfort of humanity having been lost
that they may be comp
compelled that's that coercion that we
were talking about and I think you're
going to see that at the end of time
yeah this comes from the S of Tours
right here against the
alenes and under rule four you're
looking at a uh a rule that went into
effect around the 12th century here with
this
statement I I remember we the first time
you came on to do a show with us was
about pressure 2025 and Mikey who was
still with us at that time he looked up
blue law and he showed you that there
were blue laws I believe don't quote me
on this but I believe it was either West
Virginia or Virginia where they said if
you do not go to church on Sunday then
the first punishment it was something
like no buying or selling and then then
it was like getting um lashed MH uh or
scourged or something like that and then
the last step was death I me and this
was in the United States I did um I have
seen the blue laws before and I looked
it up before and there's this website a
secular website called today I found out
feed your brain anyone can look this up
it says what are blue laws and it's
interesting here it says the first blue
law although not called that at the time
was enacted in colonial Virginia in 1610
and it mandated mandated Church
attendance at both morning and afternoon
services on Sundays at a first time time
offender lost his provision and
allowance for a whole week wow this
makeing me think of buying and selling
you cannot buy or sell because we're
going to apparently they had a system
where there was an allowance given and
if you didn't you weren't seen at church
on Sunday morning and evening you had
your allowance cut off for a whole week
the second offense in addition to losing
his allowance would be whipped what and
a third violation was supposedly
punished by Death though there's debate
over whether accounts of early blue laws
were in some cases exaggerated or not so
you think about this prophetically
you're enforcing worship like Revelation
says with the penalty of losing your
allowance or ability to buy and sell and
persecution and death exactly what
Revelation talks about so and there's so
many blue laws still in place we might
not adhere by them anymore but they're
lost that say you clo uh you can't um
you know uh shop on Sunday or you can't
be on yeah basically to encourage people
to go to church on Sunday which is
interesting and and and if you are
thinking right now how does that have
anything to do with this Bible prophecy
and a mark of the beast and the Beast of
Revelation all that kind of stuff we
have a video out on our channel that
tells you again scripture by scripture
the Bible explains itself we don't need
an outside interpreter it's its own
interpreter it's points out what the
mark of the beast is so check out the
Beast Power video that we have out and
The Mark of the Beast video you will be
shocked and you need to know this stuff
so you actually see further calls here
if we go couple Pages forward forbid
under an anatha that any should presume
to keep them in their houses or on their
lands sustain them or transact any
business with
them so again we're talking about
coercion stopping all business with
those that do not believe the way they
believe and you mentioned blue laws
we're actually seeing calls now to
reinstate blue laws there's a lot of
people that want to say let's have a
federal blue law to prohibit certain
things on Sunday
so that is the understanding that we
have that we're going to be shifting
towards the beast power implementing
rules rules and laws that we as
Protestants historical Protestants
disagree with
mhm there's also statements in here
conflating and
inflating the position of the
Pope you know 2 Thessalonians 2:4
showing himself that he is God we have
an understanding here that the beast
power is going to inflate his sense of
self and his position and we've already
seen that you know when it says Vicor of
the Son of God and it's talking about in
place of Jesus Christ we've already seen
that but we see further evidence of it
here take care so that the Sheepfold may
be one it is now divided into Parts take
care at last that we lose not that
salvation that life and breath which
thou has given us for thou art Our
Shepherd Thou Art our physician Thou Art
our governor Thou Art our husbandman
Thou Art finally another God on
Earth and this is in reference to pical
power that's so crazy they're they're
just not even shy about it they're like
I am the replacement of Jesus and I am
God on earth right and I'm above the law
and above the scriptures yep yep um you
if you go forward you can see there's
another statement like the lion the king
of quadrupeds thou another lion not
another king of men only but made the
king of kings and Monarch the whole
earth wouldst bring back Allure and
recall to thy fold other sheep which are
not of this fold guard thyself therefore
with thy sword upon thy thigh oh most
Mighty for thou also Hast two swords the
spiritual and the temporal you can
actually see those those thoughts
mimicked in their flag the Vatican flag
actually James what do the colors
symbolize on the Vatican flag well
you've got spiritual and the temporal
power you've got the silver and the gold
the White and the yellow but the silver
and the gold bound together with the red
cord symbolize the unity of church and
state or wow civil and uh Spiritual
Authority yes and this country was
founded on the principle the principle
that we do not have church and state
that have to be separated because these
these Christians that came with the
Mayflower they came from Europe and they
said we are fleeing church and state
combined that causes persecution because
there should be freedom of Rel religion
and now we see a lot of even Protestant
Christians saying no we want church and
state back this to be combined um and
this is why on this channel we speak
against it so much because it is going
to attack your religious freedom and
it's a response right it's a response to
the prevalent atheism and basically
Godless society that has crept in I
understand why they're saying it yeah I
understand that it comes from very
genuine hearts but I don't think that
everybody truly understands the danger
of it and and we're not sitting here
saying we're better than you we know
this stuff and you don't we we want to
share what the Bible says so that we can
all know the truth and the truth sets us
free and we can say you know what this
is not okay if I want to worship God
freely then we cannot have church and
state combined right right there's
another quote here but weep not daughter
of Sion for behold the king of the tribe
of Judah the root of David comes behold
God has raised up for thee a savior who
shall save you from the hands of the
spoilers we have expected thee Oh Most
Blessed Leo as the Savior that was to
come so you read all this and you think
they're talking about God but they're
not M they're talking about again that
pontifical
power dangerous dangerous stuff right
so one of the things that's interesting
is we kind of shift into a discussion
about well okay if this is the
Antichrist
power what is the mark of the beast what
is an understanding of that we know that
in Daniel it's mentioned that not only
is the beast power going to speak words
against the most high wear out the
Saints but it seeks to change times and
laws and we actually have evidence of
that
with the Council of
Trent the Sabbath the most glorious day
in the law has been changed into the
Lord's Day these and other similar
matters have not ceased by virtue of
Christ's teaching for he says he has has
come to fulfill the law not to destroy
it but they have been changed by the
authority of the church yep so when we
and we you see that right there so if we
have an understanding that the beast
power is going to change times and laws
boom it's right there there's only one
law in the Ten Commandments that has
both something about time right and uh
it's a law yep it's the fourth
Commandment which is the Sabbath
commandment well not only that but you
know if you look at an a seal that every
you know president or ruler or King puts
it's going to have three elements name
title and Dominion so for example Queen
Elizabeth you know Queen of England or
or whatever it's have the title Queen
name Elizabeth and Dominion of England
the fourth Commandment has that it's
God's seal it's literally what gives
authority to all the rest of the
Commandments because without the name
title and Dominion of the lawgiver well
what Authority does this law actually
have and when you think about that it's
the longest commandment and it also
starts with remember it's the only
Commandment that starts with remember
and so if you were the devil and you
were trying to attack God's law and get
people to disobey and disregard God one
of the easiest ones to attack is the one
that is the longest that starts with
remember and yet it's been forgotten by
so many for so long yeah um and we have
a prophecy that it was going to be
changed and and you came on to our show
and uh presented how uh you had the
historical documents again just like
this where you were showing no the early
Christians were actually keeping the
Sabbath because a lot of people are like
well in the Bible says this about Paul
and Paul didn't keep the Sabbath but no
like the you show it clearly from the
Bible and from history they were keeping
the Sabbath for a long time it's not a
Jewish institution well not only that
but you know one of the things that I go
to in Proverbs 31 is uh
31:5 is that those who drink wine forget
the law of God mhm like if you drink
wine um it's not for kingswell it's not
for Kings to drink strong drink L they
for get the
law Rome has this wine of
Babylon that causes men to forget the
very Commandment that God said to
remember yep yeah that's an interesting
point because the there is a beast in
Revelation that depicts uh Rome and and
the Vatican uh if you understand the
prophecies regarding that and the woman
is Babylon and she has the the wine of
the cup of of that's filled with God's
um indignation indignation um but how
how did this come about and you know the
story of Constantine how did the Sabbath
in the nutshell get changed to Sunday
worship and honorable uh and honor of
the
sun well there's Constantine's edict
that actually you know says on the
venerable day of the sun M that they
should gather and worship um and so you
see it there there's there's hints of it
earlier than that but James has an
excellent series talking about the the
Sabbath going deep into the history of
it that talks about that change you know
it's interesting you ask different
people you'll get different answers
because it was kind of a gradual
apostasy you know you have uh this
church father who said this but there
might be somebody who disagreed with him
but uh you see kind of a gradual shift
over time and you see councils starting
to get on board popes getting on board
um but a gradual shift by man not an
authoritative statement by God but
tradition uh being the the the main
Authority that was used to change yeah
and I think that the Catalyst of it all
was when Constantine a Roman Emperor
became a Christian he sort of became
converted and he said well um let's make
Christianity a nationwide
religion that's Again State and church
combined right instead of saying you
have the freedom to choose who you will
worship it says everybody's a Krishna
which is interesting because we see it
happen in the Bible with Nebuchadnezzar
who said the same thing to his people
everybody's going to follow Daniel's God
now but so Constantine comes around and
says everybody should be Christian and
um he said well in order to make it
easier for the Romans who worship all of
these pagan gods like the planets and
the Sun for them to become Christian
we're going to christianize those things
so you have these Pagan statues that now
they said oh this is Pluto or whatever
Planet they had and uh we'll make him
Peter St Peter and this is St John and
and do we still see that today yes we do
but then also they he said um you know
what uh I know that the Romans they like
the sun and they worship the sun on
Sunday which was the first day uh of the
week and they said well let's let's
we'll we'll allow for two days of
worship the Sabbath which was Friday
Sunset till Saturday Sunset and Sunday
uh or or sorry I say today it's Friday
Sunset till Saturday Sunset but back in
the day before the calendars changed it
was still the seventh day of the week
Sunday was the first day of the week and
so they decided that uh we're going to
have two days well at that time there
was some anti-Semitism the Sabbath was
somewhat considered to be Jewish even
the Sabbath even though lots of
protestant Christians were keeping it
and over many many many years it became
less popular and Sunday baby became more
popular and that's how the shift
happened so a lot of people say like oh
you know keeping the seventh day that's
not a historical fact you know I mean we
know we Catholics will say you know we
we've got history dating back and people
were only ever keeping Sunday and it's
like no we we have documents that talk
about it elsewise and and say something
different because even this decrum the
oldest book that we have here mentions
this on page
1297 it says it has come to my ears that
certain men of perverse Spirit have sown
among you some things that that are
wrong and opposed to the Holy Faith so
as to forbid any work being done on the
Sabbath day what else can I call these
but preachers of
antichrist so if you think about the Ten
Commandments What is the what is the
fourth Commandment it's the Sabbath day
it's to
rest and so you know they're they
actually made it kind of an onerous
thing to observe the Sabbath
uh because right after that quote they
say out of reverence for the Lord's
burial we ought to fast on the Sabbath
so it was like that's not biblical right
and so they're saying in one hand no no
you you can't not work you have to work
on that day but then also you have to
fast yeah so they just make it extra
difficult for you to keep the savath
right because they want to you know
enforce their day of false worship
instead and have that be oh well that's
a feast day you know that's that's a
celebration of Christ Resurrection
that's what we we want to do and that's
this is what a lot of the Protestant
faiths over the years eventually kind of
capitulated and took part of saying okay
well we'll we'll keep Sunday yeah and
and what's interesting too is as we're
talking about Sun worship and Sunday
just look up some of the symbolism of
both the Jesuits and the Roman Catholic
Church it's full of sun worship
symbolism full of it yeah you have the
the sign where it shows like a sun with
the Rays coming out um all the time
y so if we go forward um there's also a
quote here talking about Sunday although
it is enjoined by the precept of Divine
Law to abstain from all survial work on
Sundays and holidays yet some
transgressing this precept in rural
works and handicrafts days presume to
exercise the afores said lest therefore
by transgression of this kind the
faithful people incur the indignation of
almighty God we decided that no one on
Sundays and the worship festivals dare
to practice Manual Arts without any
urgent necessity or evident piety and
then of the special permission of the
priest and transgressors of the
prefect's confession are to be punished
by the sentence of excommunication by
their ordinaries and you know
excommunication was almost like akin to
a sentence of death because you know the
the teaching elsewhere was that it was
not murder to go kill somebody who is
excommunicated
H so are we going to see any of this
repeated yes according to Revelation 13
we will Mark the
Beast now what's interesting is in these
books themselves they actually admit
that there were people that were keeping
the
Sabbath uh back in those days we command
all Christians to observe the Lord's day
to be held not in honor of the past
Sabbath but on account of that Holy
Night of the first of the week called
the Lord's day when speaking of that
Sabbath which the Jews observe the last
day of the week which would be what day
that would be Sabbath right or or
Saturday MH and which also our peasants
observe so we we have them admitting
right here that the peasants
observed what they called The Jewish
Sabbath which is this the seventh day of
the week Saturday and this comes from
the Council of froli here looking at the
year
791 so long before the wild denes you
had people who were peasants who kept
and obeyed remembered God's law mhm now
now we're talking about making a heart
statement well the sa the seventh day
was the Sabbath Sunday was the first day
of the week and the calendars have
changed which is why now most calendars
show Sunday as seventh day and I've read
before that people have post this in the
comments they have other theories about
how that's not true how do we know that
these calendars have changed and that
we're actually still keeping the
original seventh day well the Jews for
one still keep the seventh day but
remember two when in in terms of the
calendar changing uh if you go back to
Gregory uh and of course the the change
to the you know Gregorian from the
Julian calendars was that it didn't
actually change the days of the week it
changed the numbering for like the month
but it didn't actually change the weekly
uh cycle at all mhm so you know it's I
see that argument all the time but if
you go back and actually look it up it
didn't change the numeration for the
days of the week at all yeah so we're
still keeping Sabbath the way God
designed it at creation but you're
seeing the Lines Blurred now because if
you type into Google and say what's the
first day of the week what day is the
seventh day of the week you'll get
conflicting answers yep sometimes it'll
tell you that oh the seventh day of the
week is Sunday no that's not correct
right yeah um and so there're there's
trying to blur the lines there when we
have it said right here that the
peasants would worship on the seventh
day y that that the Jews kept in in
other languages many other languages
Saturday we say Saturday because of the
Roman name Saturn yes that they
worshiped but in other many other
languages Saturday is actually some form
of Sabbath so it's Sab yeah
exactly
yeah so if you go to the Council of
leoda that's was actually a major issue
there uh Christians must not judaize by
resting on the Sabbath but must work on
that day rather honoring the Lord's day
and if they can resting then as
Christians but if any shall be found to
be judaizers let them be anatha from
Christ so what's funny here is that they
mention the Lord's day and they keep
using that as a reference to Sunday
trying to trying to you know say that
the Lord's day is
Sunday but go back to the Bible doesn't
it say that Jesus is Lord of the Sabbath
mhm mhm so what what is his day yeah
it's true he even came to the the Jewish
temple on the Sabbath day as was his
custom right yeah so we know that when
the the true Lord's day is the Sabbath
yeah they're trying to separate the two
and say well the Sabbath is different
from the Lord's day when a true
understanding of scripture is that those
are actually one and the same mhm the
first day of the week has no reverence
to it at all it even says in the gospels
that Jesus died on a Friday he
preparation day he rested on the Sabbath
day and that he rose on the first day um
but the thing is is what did he do on
the Sabbath day even in death he rested
he rested M he honored the Sabbath day
and you can also see that he had just
died and some people say well that's
when the Sabbath was done away with but
when why right after he died did he keep
the Sabbath and besides the ladies who
came to embalm his body wanted to embalm
him and realize he was risen so but then
in Matthew 24 right he's talking about
the end times the disciples come to him
and they ask him they're like you know
tell us when are these things going to
be what shall be the sign of that coming
and in the end of the world right Y and
he starts going through and he lists all
these different things you know there's
going to be Wars rumors of wars famines
pestilences plagues you know false
Christ false prophets shall arrive they
shall deceive many you know he goes
through this whole long thing and and
then he says pray that your flight be
not in the winter neither on the Sabbath
day M and so we know that clearly that
commandment wasn't done away with else
why would he tell them to not try and
flee on the Sabbath day and that was
long after his death exactly so we know
that that a Sabbath remains I mean Paul
talks about saying that you know
therefore there remaineth a day mhm so
if we have reference in these books of
the Sabbath being kept by The Peasants
mhm is it not unreasonable to assume
that the day was changed because as as
prophesied by Daniel 7 saying that you
know it shall seek to change times and
laws is it not unreasonable to assume
everyone's been duped yeah modern
Christendom has been duped into
believing a lie yeah and and lots of
people say but the majority keeps Sunday
how could they be wrong but the majority
rejected Christ when he came that's very
true especially the
leaders you know they talk about it
being a tradition for Christians for
many years but it was a tradition that
was brought about through coercion yes
MH and I think you've got a slide about
that here from the Council of Naran
where those who violated Sunday rest a
slave could receive 100 stripes in other
words you were beaten unless you kept
what the church decreed yep and the same
we saw in those blue laws I mentioned
earlier which I I believe was uh in
Virginia this is not service to God out
of love this is service to God out of
fear and such kind of obedience uh based
on the principle of self-preservation
instead of out of love is worth nothing
to God yeah if you're just obeying
because of the benefit that you can get
then that's that's not true religion
yeah and these were not true Christians
either the the the people in charge and
we're not talking about the Catholic
people back in those days where
everybody was Catholic or today who are
in part of the system we're not talking
about them these are there's so many
beautiful Catholic people who just don't
know anything about this who are part of
the system but if they would understand
the truth would be readily ready to
leave right we're not condemning those
people we're not hating on Catholics
we're talking about the Fulfillment of
Bible prophecy that we cannot do
anything else but to tell people the
truth out of love if some if there is
something going to happen to you that is
going to deceive you that's going to
literally destroy your Eternal salvation
if you go along with this system
wouldn't it be loving to call them out
and tell them the truth and that's what
we're doing that's what we're doing
right here yeah it's not against any
individual Catholic there's there's
wonderful Catholics out there that that
don't know they don't know the history y
uh the issue is with the system of
worship the system of coercion that has
persecuted and condemned people for
believing God's word yep and for wanting
to further God's
work so James you had some interesting
discussions about these books right here
in that the
Jesuits they started to get a lot of
heat essentially for people realizing
that this is a fulfillment of Prophecy
this is a fulfillment of the Antichrist
power and so as a result you know you
had this building momentum behind the
Protestant movement so how did they try
and shift the blame away from the
Catholic church so Rome had to counter
the Protestant Reformation that was
really beginning to expose her and one
of the things that she did to do that
was you know at the fifth leran Council
December 1516 there was actually a
Prohibition against studying when
Antichrist was going to come forth they
actually prohibited studying the signs
or seasons for the judgment and for the
Antichrist and uh when the Antichrist
would come but really what we see with
the Jesuits is in The Counter
Reformation we see two splits occurring
we have alkazar introducing preterism
and then we have rera and Luna
introducing futurism and I want to show
you what this did here to the
understanding of uh of the Antichrist
power in the 1260 years that were
mentioned in Bible prophecy historicism
had identified those 1260 years as the
Dark Ages uh to the French Revolution
from 538 to 1798 really beginning with
Justinian's codex declaring the pope
head of all the churches and Napoleon's
codex coming along and ending papal
Supremacy but Rome said nope we're going
to go ahead and Outlaw that and say
that's not correct we need to discourage
that kind of thinking we're going to
introduce either ISM through Alcazar or
we're going to introduce futurism
through Luna now preterism looked at
Revelation chapters 1 through 11 and
described it as the Jews and the
destruction of Jerusalem by the Romans
and really focusing on Pagan Rome so
Antichrist is identified as Caesar Nero
and the judgment period all those
prophecies occurred thousands of years
ago it's all deep in the past now Rome
doesn't care which side you buy you can
either buy preterism or future so long
as you take the focus off her she
doesn't care and so there's many people
today who take either side but you have
rera right here who was a Jesuit doctor
of Theology and introduced this idea
that the Antichrist a single individual
would persecute and blaspheme the saints
of God rebuild the Temple in Jerusalem
abolish the Christian religion deny
Jesus Christ be received by the Jews
pretend to be God kill the two witnesses
of God and conquer the world it sounds
very similar to what evangelicals teach
today there's good reason for that
because they bought this idea from Rome
Manuel Luna wrote this book called
Vanita Del messas in Gloria majestad and
you can see right there
compo uh Juan yosaf Ben Ezra he actually
wrote it under the pen name of Rabbi Ben
Ezra and so to kind of better better
mask and better Shield himself he wrote
it under a pen name of a Jew wait wait
so so basically this was a Jesuit uhuh
who we talked about Jesuits were trying
to infiltrate with Protestant church not
saying I'm a
Jesuit everybody I'm a Roman Catholic
I've come to do this they're like I am a
Protestant right it's clo and Dagger it
is so so so interesting Scotty who who
you know is one of our team members he
once went to a church Protestant Church
Christian Church it was in his younger
years we just started coming back to
Christianity and he was in the services
and and somebody was hired on I think it
was a youth pastor or like an associate
pastor and he started noticing the
services started to change it started
getting more Rowdy more loud and the
Bible was more set to the side you know
and then he um he this is like the LA
area he moves away from La years later
he gets a call from somebody who was
like Yeah remember that guy yeah so he
was there for years the church went
downhill and then one day one of the
church members was invited to go I don't
know why they were there they were
invited to go to a Catholic service I
guess they knew somebody who's like we
should come with me for something so
they you go and they're like wait a
minute that's the same guy that's the
priest was literally the same guy doing
the services on Sunday but in his old
church that Scotty attended at the time
he was also the pastor why would that be
I I mean I don't know if that was a
Jesuit but it sounds very Jesuit to me
so for people who are saying it doesn't
happen anymore and like you're saying
they're in Disguise yeah and somebody
actually handw wrote over to the right
there Luna actually clarifying what this
book is from because it doesn't actually
bear his name on it but that's the
that's the kind of stuff that they did
and you know here in the text you can
see right here some of this idea of
futurism where he talks about in such
way that the resurrected ones and
reigned with Christ that is spoken of
here are not only beheaded or the
martyrs but also expressly those who did
not worship the Beast His Image uh nor
take his character on their foreheads or
hands all of which is spoken of in this
chapter of Revelation speaking of
Revelation 13 but that it follows
evidently that the Myster mystery of the
first resurrection of which we are
speaking must happen not before after
the Beast then is a mystery neither that
is neither past nor present but very
future since the Beast which is by their
confession interpreters is the
Antichrist Is Yet To Come mhm futurism
exactly so this this future Antichrist
now the sad reality is is here we have
some of these Protestants who bought it
you've got Edward Irving and you've got
John Derby and they helped translate
this work by Luna to English bring it to
the United States and you can see how it
it seeped in another individual who was
involved here was Mar Margaret McDonald
a 15-year-old Scottish girl member of
Edward Irving's congregation who had
these Visions in 1830 that included a
secret Rapture of Believers before the
appearance of the Antichrist she
informed Irving of her Visions by letter
and attended the prophecy conferences
that began in Dublin Ireland in 1830 at
powerscore Castle where he promoted both
futurism and a secret Rapture so this is
where the secret Rapture comes from yeah
that Christians believe yeah yeah so
wait these I I thought that people
Christians who believe in a secet
Rapture we're just studying the Bible
and we're like okay well this is what it
means this is how we interpret it but
that's the origin of it it's a person
all roads lead to Rome what well and you
know the the the sad reality of this is
is that people don't realize that the
devil is just as capable of of offering
false signs and wonders that you know
people can get misled and sadly you know
we have individuals like this who were
you know not testing these Visions by
the Bible yeah the Bible says by the law
and by the testimony if they did not
speak according to these things it's
because there is no light in them they
you have to if you have visions and
dreams which it is biblical to have
visions and dreams in the last days it
does say that but if you have them check
them with the word of God if it doesn't
add up it's not from the lord well we
all have a personal responsibility to
read and understand the scriptures for
ourselves exactly yeah you know where
this uh thought content trickled down to
is that Dallas Theological Seminary a
non-denominational Protestant school you
can see this filtering down their
prophetic eschatology you got people
like Jan or or John walv you got Chuck
Swindle you got Charles ryy Vernon McGee
Kenneth Taylor Tim Le you know The Moody
Institute in Chicago the Moody press
they're all you know Downstream taking
these kinds of views of the end times M
Tim Le was involved with the what was
this these books called again
Left Behind series Left Behind series Y
and by the way um Dallas Jenkins dad was
involved with that Dallas Jenkins being
the director of The Chosen interesting
fact yeah you know and Jerry fwell of
course Trinity Broadcasting Network uh
now I think that's their now defunct
Center there but um they've had you know
two futurist themed movies The Omega
Code and megiddo and uh you've got the
Gathering DRC Productions uh end of the
Harvest the Cristiano film group Jack
vanp Ministries and Jerry fwell John
haggy all of these folks Hilton Sutton
uh Perry Stone all all of these folks
teaching Downstream these kinds of
theological positions which again Rome
has been very effective in taking the
heat off of her by either teaching
preterism or futurism yeah it doesn't
matter which one you buy but if you can
take either one of those positions and
be blind to what's right in the middle
Satan would love that people to be
either nearsighted or farsighted in
Bible prophecy and Miss what's right
before them yeah again preterism being
the Antichrist has been in the past
futurism being it's in the future and
all of this is literally Jesuit Doctrine
yep we are historicist MH we're right
smack in the middle and recognizing the
Antichrist power directly where he ruled
for 1260 years for the Beast that was
not
uh or was is not and yet is you know
Revelation talked about this power that
that was in the past rule 1260 years is
not and there's a time period where it
receives a deadly wound and no longer
has power but will return at the end of
time and the problem is is that all of
these Ministries do not recognize the
power that's going to return at the end
of time is exactly the power that ruled
in the past and that's Roman Catholicism
yep well and there was a deadly wound
right there's a deadly wound wound that
is is being healed and that deadly wound
is the removal of state power mhm they
they have the religious power but the
the state power got taken away remember
they wanted to combine the two that's
what we talked about on the flag and
everything is a combination of political
and state power yeah and it was removed
during the French Revolution right yeah
this is all history right but that power
is being given back to Rome in Spades
now with Pope Francis oh yeah you can
see him speaking to the United Nations
he just went to Belgium and you can see
him speaking to the G7 which is all the
major economic countries that come
together to to talk the economy what on
Earth has the pope to do with the
economy like like you're a religious
person right and my question is why are
we all looking at the pope why are we
not looking at some other pastor and
some other Christian individual why is
it just this guy because the Bible says
that they all wandered after the Beast
wander with an a meaning literally you
follow the guy y um
so pretty interesting yep but it's a
message that we have to share we have to
tell others about the great controversy
about the great controversy between
Christ and his angels and Satan and his
angels yep and how that is going to play
out in the end yeah and how we have to
be warned about it we have to have an
understanding I am blown away this was
such an awesome video and I really think
that this is going to blow some other
people away they're going to look at
this and be like I've never heard about
this before what's going on and I think
everybody that's watching the news today
knows something is happening something
is going on we are being pressed down a
funnel that we're being pushed toward a
particular ideology or a particular
mindset that hey we're coming close to
Mark the Beast we're coming close to the
beast power coming back having its wound
healed according to prophecy and that's
why I we're sharing this today again
this is not attack on beautiful Catholic
people who are in this system but again
if they if we we have to share the truth
we have to share the truth in love
because that's what Jesus calls us to do
to say look this is what the Bible says
let's follow Jesus as he is telling us
to in the word because he is coming soon
so for those of you at home thank you so
much for watching I highly recommend go
check out the video we did on the
Jesuits with James Bowen and that goes
in depth into who the Jesuits are and
what they're standing for and why
they're still alive and well today and
also make sure you check out our video
we did on what the beast power is we go
literally verse by verse by verse it's
like 30 minutes 40 minutes or something
and you know you understand why we're
saying this and also we have a video out
on what the mark of the beast is and
lastly check out James's two episodes
that he did on um what is the oh how the
Sabbath was changed to Sunday according
to the Bible according to history it's
literally irrefutable once you
understand it and see it for yourself so
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you leave a a comment below also if
you want to support our ministry we
always welcome your prayers and if you
want to support us uh financially you
can do so at or patreon.com SL Little
Light Studios we also got t-shirts we
got Christian t-shirts I'm wearing one
right now you can get this on lightwear
do shop which has our Christian merch
and of course make sure you support
James and Alex go subscribe to their
channels Heritage and Hope Ministries he
has a lot of uh videos on there is still
making videos about these books check
out his website Heritage and hop
ministries.com for pictures of what we
showed you today and they're still
uploading them as well right yes yeah
we're still getting them up there
there's more coming and James's Channel
biblical hope and James if they want you
to come to their Church you do speak at
people's churches right you do yeah no
we're we're uh we we do events at
different churches and we actually take
these books on tour so if you want us to
come to your church we can bring these
books and you can see it in person for
yourself we've had some fun taking them
it's a lot of books to carry around but
it's a lot of fun to show people and how
how can I contact you so I'm I'm on
social media you can find me on Facebook
or you can also find biblical Hope on
Facebook as well and uh drop drop me a
message there you can also contact us
through the website yeah Heritage and
hop ministries.com yep and uh you go
with them on these tours to show the
books awesome you can see both of them
so you can uh take a picture with their
books if you'd like and and share this
with your friends and your family so
thank you guys for watching make sure
you hit subscribe like and we'll see you
next
[Music]
time cre you
Jacob and he form you
isra will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God he shall go out no more
I will ride on him the name of my
God and the
power
shall
[Music]
shall by every word that proceeds from
the mouth of God
all right I can do
this all
[Music]
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's the
mean oh thank you you know we're all
made with a unique fingerprint but we're
all God's artwork wow where'd you get
it lightwear wear your Witness
[Music]
I